hallo liebe zuschauer und herzlich
willkommen zurück bei easy german wir
sind heute in münster und zwar sind wir
heute in der kreuzstraße einer der
bekanntesten kneifen straßen von münster
nachts ist hier immer sehr viel los und
es ist vor allem unter studenten sehr
beliebt die haben wir eine kneipe nach
der anderen und ihr habt uns ja schon
mal gefragt könnt ihr denn nicht mal
eine episode machen in einer typisch
deutschen kneipe genau das machen wir
heute für euch wir stehen hier vor dem
himmel und hölle eine stadtbekannte
studentenkneipe wir treffen gleich einen
besonderen gast und wir schauen uns
jetzt immer um
oder kommt er auch schon unser gastgeber
des heutigen tages überraschungen
wünscht das ist aber nur überraschen
simon
wir haben uns mit eva briegel bzw lasst
uns eingeladen
es ist richtig warum sind wir denn hier
mit dir heute habe ich gehört gibt es
einen super sprachkurs über einen
fundamentalen aspekte der deutschen
sprache nämlich das biertrinken richtig
und wieso bist du dafür qualifiziert
bestimmt habt ihr schon angekündigt
himmel und hölle da sind wir heute und
da arbeite ich
nein doch ich arbeite ja du machst das
quasi neben dem studium ja genau damit
finanziere ich mein studium ist uns mit
rein
aber jan auch geht's
ich muss ja sagen ich habe in meinem
leben schon viel zeit in der kneipe
verbracht sehr viel zeit und ich war
noch nie hinter der theke und ich hab
auch noch nie mit jemandem über so
kneipen insider sachen gesprochen
deswegen werde ich heute alle fragen die
ich jemals hatte zur kneipe an simon
stellen
mach ich dir auch kein großes wir haben
nur eine größe man muss ja dazu sagen
dass es vielleicht auch ein insider wenn
ihr noch nie in deutschland war in
unterschiedlichen regionen deutschland
sind die biere unterschiedlich groß dass
zum beispiel ist 05 04 04 ist hier das
größte in 04 in bayern ist nicht mehr
existent
da ist das kleinste bieren nämlich 05
simon ich hätte gern für janisch und für
mich zwei bier zwei bier satz aber eins
ist schon fertig auf den wunderschönen
deckel ein bier kostet 280 folglich 25
euro 60 bitte mach sechs dankeschön
trinkgeld wichtig dass man natürlich
auch erklären in deutschland halten gibt
man trinkt hält das ist ja von land zu
land unterschiedlich in deutschland was
gibt man so an trinkgeld simon
ich würde sagen so zu sieben prozent
immer ganz gut sie müssten also war etwa
das hängt davon ab wo man hingeht
gehobener gibt natürlich ein bisschen
mehr
und wenn ich habe jetzt fünf euro 60
zahlen müssen habe sechs euro dem ist
das gut so so standard simon nimmt jetzt
eine bestellung entgegen
in den armen was ja ich hätte gern noch
ein wechsel noch ein großes bier bitte
als nachricht
oktober
haben wir denn da schnaps gebrannt
simons haben wir denn da den höhen
brandes unser haus schnaps den mixen wir
selber bei der vernetzungs was da drin
ist ja klar dass kinder auf euch ja auch
das ist kneipenkultur tief toiletten auf
der treppe sind ja traditionell immer
sehr voll geschrieben mit sprüchen und
auf der männertoilette das wollte ich
euch mal zeigen auf vermehrte mögen
vielleicht manchmal ein paar derbe
sprüche dabei sein
auf der frauentoilette ist das relativ
harmlos hier schreiben leute zum
beispiel so was wie auf allerbeste
freunde oder sie kündigen ihre hochzeit
an sehr populär auch auf der toilette
der kneipe hochzeit 31 zehnter 2014
sr gleichlauf wir lieben euch alle
spektakuläre sprüche hier auf der
toilette ich geh mal rein hier
kathrin ist die geilste sau der welt
damit dass alle wissen
jasmin und klarer sind die schönsten
scheiße simon was ist das denn das ist
ein meter bier dürfen wir das mit film
was habt ihr gerade bestellt
und was ist das lang ist aber ihr seid
nur zu zweit für jeden halben meter das
billiger ok dann sind wir mal gespannt
wie lange er für den meter bier braucht
ist übrigens günstiger 1 geschenkt und
er ausrichten hundes nicht bar fixe ein
metallgestell
das ist aber lecker dass wir hier das
ist aber lecker sieht man ich habe
selten so lag rissbildungen wenn ihr aus
dem ausland kommt freut ihr euch sicher
wir sind eigentlich so die preise in
deutschland in einer kneipe hier auf dem
ein beispiel schnäpse ab 1 euro
longdrinks ab 52 flaschenbier euro 30
pils vom fass 280 cocktails ab 93
das ist auch für deutschland relativ
günstig und war sicher dass seine
typische studentenkneipe in anderen
knallten kann es auch leicht teurer sein
was habt ihr gerade gestellt ich hab
gerade du und ich habe einen diese
bestellt was ist denn ein diesel ein
diesel des pilz mit cola gemischten
trinkst du es öfters das trinke ich
immer ja was ist der ford immer also
wenn ich alkohol trinke trinke ich immer
mit viel wald pilz vertraglich nicht so
gut sind so stark oder nicht und was du
trinkst normales bild ja dann fängt man
eigentlich in deutschland an zu trinken
ich habe gehört es fängt so zwischen
14.15 an illegalerweise erlaubt es dir
ab 16 harte drinks ab 18
denkst du dass ist gut dass man so früh
anfängt
oder schlecht hängt vom standpunkt ab
also für die teenager ist das sicher gut
in anführungsstrichen weil sie ein spaß
damit haben anführungsstrichen genau
von der physiologischen seite muss man
sagen alkohol ist ein nervengift trinkt
das nicht so liebe leute das war's mit
unserer heutigen episode ihr seht
mittlerweile ist die kneipen voll
als wir angefangen haben war sie immer
noch ganz alleine erledigt auch so macht
wir haben mit dem verein gesprochen
wir hoffen es hat euch gefallen gelaufen
tschüss mittlerweile hast du was zu tun
oder doch bisschen was los wäre jetzt
noch voller heute das wird folgen
dann wünschen wir noch eine gute schicht
und wir verabschieden uns von euch danke
fürs zuschauen danke für eure
unterstützung schreibt uns mal wieder
eure kommentare und eure fragen
beantworten wir die nächste woche bei
calais antwortet was gibt es noch fragen
zur deutschen freiheiten die wir heute
muss beantwortet haben einmal zum ich
dachte ein einige schreibt sie uns in
die kommentare beim gewissen schauen und
bis zur nächsten woche bitte danke danke
carina noch gleich
gleich die zwei sind die gleichen
er gleicht